So I just got a really fun haul in from commence,
and let's do a little try on Princess in the Meadow.
I love it. It's a perfect dress for me for just, like,
every day. I can run around with my kids with it,
which is a little dangerous and white,
but, you know,
we live dangerously.
And white is such a year round color here in Charleston.
I know some people say not to wear it after Labor Day,
but we don't adhere to rules. Right?
And this is a coastal town.
White is a all year round color.
Oh,
so cute. So the next one is this little red dress,
which when I saw this, I was like,
this is absolutely me. I love a red dress.
My style is a little bit more like,
vintage inspired, and this is the perfect,
like, little out on the town summer dress.
This is probably how I would style it with, like,
super cute accessories. It also cinches in,
in the back, which I really like,
so it gives you really nice lines.
Adorable. Love it.
Okay, the last one is, like,
very sexy nighttime, which is a little at my wheelhouse,
so let's try it. Okay,
stop it.
Who is she?
I don't usually wear things like this with, like,
the low back and, like,
the strap around this. That's a lot of side boob, too.
Okay. But it's so sexy and it's very comfortable.
This is definitely a Date night outfit.
Summer date night. Cause it's still very hot.
Um. Oh,
but I love it. Which one's your favorite?
Let me know in the comments.